بعد يومين هندخل في شهر فبراير اللي هو
شهر عيد الحب اللي بيصادف يوم 14 فبراير
والاحباب بيحضروا في هذا اليوم ايش يجيبوا
هدايا لبعدهم كيف تكون الهديه مميزه وكذا
وحركاته ومطاعم واشياء من هذا النوع بس
لكن في خبري الهديه ما راح تكون للي احباب
فعليين فلاحين يعني يعتقد انه اقتراح
الاقتراح الان في هذه الان في هذه الخبر
للاحباب السابقين وتحديدا لان النهايات
يعني بينهم ما كانت سعيده ففي حديقه حيوان
في الولايات المتحده اعلنت انه مقابل خمسه
او عشره او 20 دولار يقدر اي شخص يروح على
الحديقه يسمى حشره باسم حبيب صادق
ويرميها بعدين كطعام لاحد الحيوانات في
الحديقه لاحلى انه الشخص اللي بتحط اسمه
بيوصل له كمان بطاقه الكترونيه من الحديقه
بمناسبه عيد الحب ومكتوب فيها انه كان
وجبه خفيفه لاحد الحيوانات اللي فيها وال
لو احلى انه مقابل عاد 100$ يعني الواحد
لو بحبح شويه بيتم تصوير فيديو خاص
للحيوان وهو بياكل الحشره اللي عليها اسم
الحبيب السابق وارسالها
بصراحه فكره متعب عليها يعني انتقاميه كده
ممتازه يعني